pamela was asked to find where h of x
equals x to the third minus six x
squared plus twelve x has a relative
extrema m-- this is her solution so step
one it looks like she tried to take the
derivative step two
she tries to find the solution find
where the derivative is equal to zero
and she found that it happens at x
equals two so she says that's a critical
point in step three she says she makes a
conclusion that therefore h has a
relative extremum there it's Pamela's
work correct if not what's her mistake
so pause this video and try to work
through it yourself and see if panels
work is correct all right well I'm just
going to try to do it again in parallel
so first let me just take the derivative
here so H prime of X just use the power
rule multiple times it's going to be
three x squared for the X to the third
two times negative 6 is negative twelve
or minus 12x and the derivative of 12x
is plus 12 and let's see you can factor
out a three here so it's three times x
squared minus four X plus four and this
part is indeed equal to X minus two
squared so this is equal to three times
X minus two squared so her step one
looks right on target okay step two the
solution the H prime of X is equal equal
to zero is equal to x equals two yeah
that works out if you were to say if you
were to say three times X minus two
squared which is H prime of X the first
derivative and set that equal to zero
this is going to be true when X is equal
to two and so any point where your first
derivative is equal to zero or it's
undefined it is indeed a critical point
so this step looks good so far and then
step three H has a relative extrema m--
at x equals two alright so she made a
big conclusion here she assumed that
because the derivative was 0 that we
have a relative extrema so let's just
see if you can even just make that
conclusion in order to have a relative
extrema
your curve is going to look something
like this and then you would have a
relative extrema right over here and
over here your slope goes from being
positive to and then it hits the
and then it goes to being negative or
you can have a relative extremum like
this this would be this would be a
maximum point this would be a minimum
point right over here and then in a
minimum point your slope is zero right
over there but right before it your
slope was negative and it goes to being
positive but you actually have cases
where your derivative your first
derivative is zero but you aren't you
don't have an extremum so for example
you could have a point like this where
right over here your slope or your
derivative could be equal to zero and so
your first derivative would be equal to
zero but notice your slope is positive
it hits here and then it goes back to
being positive again and so you can't
make the conclusion just because your
derivative is zero that it's definitely
an extremum you could say it's a
critical point and so step two is
correct in order to make this conclusion
you would have to test what the
derivative is doing before that point
and after that point and verify that it
is switching sides and we could try to
do that so let's make a little table
here make a little table a little bit
neater so X X H prime of X right over
here we know at x equals to H prime of
two is zero that's our critical point
but let's try I don't know let's see
what happens when X is equal to one and
then let's see what happens when x
equals three I'm just sampling points on
either side of two and let's see we are
going to have when X is equal to one H
prime of 1 is 3 times 1 minus 2 squared
1 minus 2 negative 1 squared is positive
1 times 3 is still positive and then 3
well 3 minus 2 squared times 3 that's
also going to be 3 so this is actually a
situation where actually like I've just
drawn it where our slope is positive
before we hit the critical point it gets
to 0 but then it starts becoming
positive again and so that's why you
actually have to do this test in order
to identify whether it's an extremum it
turns out that this is not an extremum
this is not a maximum or a minimum point
here so camels work is not correct and
her mistake is step three
in order to make this conclusion you
would have to test on either side of
that critical point test the first
derivative